coach asks Gary we spend all of our time
pouring our creativity into projects for
our clients so that when it's time to
shift gears and focus on our brand we're
exhausted how do you keep it burning for
both coach this simple answer here is
very simply that you need to you need to
work harder and faster there's really
nothing else I mean how do I I'm
exhausted every day but I'm making
enormous amounts of things happen in my
18 hours right not only am i working 18
hours but I'm working fast as hell in
those 18 hours and I'm prioritizing
what's important what's not and so you
know I guess the answer to your question
is we're all different I mean if you
need to be a type and rigor and
organized I would just schedule
non-negotiable time for your personal
brand if that's important to you from 6
to 7 p.m. because you have that whole
day to like kind of check the box that
you want to and you just got that time
it's just allocated maybe that time is a
10 to midnight but really there's no
magic answer here the answer is more
time and faster within that time I think
the faster part confuses a lot of people
right I always talk about like stop
watching lost sleep less but there's
another variable be much faster in the
hours that you're actually in like these
guys can tell you there is not a second
that's down I love when people guy I
work 10 hours a day and then when I
oughta them there was like 15 minutes
here where they watched our YouTube
video like I mean like just literally
every second like we fight for minutes
here we fight for seconds here I wish
those other cameras showing you how hard
the bobble heads are on the crew here
every minute and so like my gut is
because I when I thought I was the
biggest workaholic that ever lived
from 22 to 30 and running Wine Library
but I had enough time to [ __ ] about
baseball with Brandon for nine minutes
or talk to my dad about something 4:15
that made no sense and did it matter or
went to espn.com to just check Jets
score like I had time I had time I'm
dramatically faster at 39 that I was at
29 and I'm working more hours that's how
it's happening I know the answer I lived
it I I am making fun of 29 year old Gary
b4
all the spewing that I do that dude
wasn't as fast and didn't go for as long
every day and that's just how I've done
it